Well, my name is Lisa Ray and you could say I'm an accidental actress.
I believe cinema is about connecting with your humanity.
There are good films and there are bad films, and then there are Bollywood films.
Bollywood simply has its own grammar, its own way of doing things.
It's really larger than life. It was a great experience to sort of be a part of that world...
...for a certain period of time.
But, I'm Canadian and so my sensibility is a lot more...
...I guess in terms of cinema, is expressed a lot more humanistic.
It's a lot more real and naturalistic.
Indian culture is very, very strong...
...and it kind of tends to like, overshadow a lot of other cultures, that's sort of my experience.
I guess, I lean most towards Buddhist philosophy.
But there's a big overlap as well between Hinduism and Buddhism and again it all depends on what...
...brand of Hinduism are you talking about. It was my acting that led me actually towards Buddhism.
In June 2009, I was diagnosed with multiple myeloma,...
...which is a cancer of the plasma cells in the bone marrow...
...and I immediately started treatment.
I'm on the road to recovery. I think that the healing begins when you realize there's no cure.
It's really a lot healthier to sort of surrender some aspect of our lives.